Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Julius Caesar has just got his command, the long-anticipated command that he wanted to bring him wealth, fame, status and power. So he's going off to Gaul to fight Asterix, versus Getterix and so on and so forth.
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。欢迎回到《The Rest Is History》。尤利乌斯·恺撒刚刚获得了他的指挥权，这是他期待已久的指挥权，能为他带来财富、名望、地位和权力。所以他要前往高卢，去对抗阿斯特里克斯（Asterix）、维钦托利（Vercingetorix）等等。
And that's basically what happens, isn't it, Tom? I mean, Caesar claims that he kills a million people. That's the report of Plutarch, writing a century or so later, he says. Over the course of the conquest of Gaul, Caesar slaughtered a million and enslaved another million. So is this as true as the talking snakes in the story of Alexander the Great? I think it's likely to be true. I mean, it's likely to derive from claims made by caesar himself right this was seen as kind of glorious bloody feats yeah um caesar's caesar's conquest of all is completely illegal under roman law
汤姆，这基本上就是所发生的事情，不是吗？我的意思是，恺撒声称他杀了一百万 人。普鲁塔克在 一个多世纪后写作时记载说，在征服高卢的过程中，恺撒屠杀了 一百万，并奴役了另外一百万。那么，这就像亚历山大大帝故事中会说话的蛇一样真实吗？我认为这很可能是真的。我的意思是，它很可能源于恺撒本人所做出的宣称，对吧？这被视为一种光荣的血腥功绩，是的……嗯，恺撒对高卢的征服在罗马法律下是完全非法的。
actually caesar himself had brought in a law saying that uh the governors of provinces shouldn't go on kind of um glory raids beyond the frontiers of their provinces that's exactly what caesar does um he uh he crosses the rhine he famously crosses the channel to britain uh it's it's an incredibly bloody brutal ultimately glorious process um and it brings caesar exactly what he wants exactly what he wants it makes what he wants. It makes him famous. He writes his own reports. You know, it's like, isn't it the Churchill thing that history will be kind to me? Because I intend to write it. Yes. So Caesar does that, his famous commentaries.
事实上，恺撒自己曾颁布一项法律，规定……嗯，各省总督不应该在其省份边境之外进行某种……嗯，荣耀突袭。而这正是恺撒所做的……嗯，他……他跨越了莱茵河，他著名的跨越海峡去了不列颠……这是一个极其血腥、残酷、最终却很光荣的过程……它带给了恺撒他所想要的一切，完全是他所想要的……它让他出名。他撰写自己的战报。你知道，这就像丘吉尔的那句话，历史会对我很宽容吗？因为我打算书写历史。是的。所以恺撒就是这么做的，他的著名战地评注。
So he makes sure that everyone back in Rome is kept abreast of his great feats, which he reports in a tone of kind of sober modesty, which is all the more effective for that yeah and he starts to lavish money on the people uh bribing um high flyers in the senate um he recruits large numbers of legions um so that the 13th legion which he will take to the rubicon he's he's recruited that in i think um 58 57 bc and it's followed him across Gaul. Now, all of this, of course, back in Rome, where large chunks of the Roman elite regard him rather as AC Grayling would regard Nigel Farage. I mean, that's the kind of, that's how Caesar is hated. You know, it's how Caesar is hated. Right. You know, it's how Remainers view Boris Johnson. Yeah. It's that level of hatred.
因此，他确保罗马的每个人都能随时了解他的伟大功绩，他在战报中带着一种清醒而谦逊的语气，这反而使之更具效果。是的，他开始向人民挥霍金钱……嗯，贿赂参议院中的风云人物……他招募了大量的军团，因此他将带到卢比孔河的第十三军团，是他大约在公元前58或57年招募的，并且它一路跟随他穿过了高卢。现在，所有这一切，当然，都传回了罗马，在那里，罗马精英阶层的大部分人看待他，就像AC·格雷林（AC Grayling）看待奈杰尔·法拉奇（Nigel Farage）那样。我的意思是，这就是那种……这就是恺撒被痛恨的程度。你知道的，这就是恺撒被痛恨的程度。没错。你知道的，这就是留欧派看待鲍里斯·约翰逊的方式。是的。就是那种程度的仇恨。
Hatred and fury at continued success, right? And envy and jealousy. Yeah. And, of course, back in Rome, Pompey and Crassus still hate each other. So there's every prospect that the tranvirate will fall to pieces. It's not an official arrangement. It's a kind of shadowy behind the scenes agreement of the kind that had always operated in Rome. It's just that these three men are so powerful that they really can basically run Rome as they want. But by 56, Pompey and Crassus are falling
对持续成功的仇恨和愤怒，对吧？还有嫉妒。是的。而且，当然，在罗马，庞培和克拉苏仍然互相仇恨。所以三头同盟有可能会彻底崩溃。这不是一个官方的安排，而是一种隐秘的、幕后的协议，就像罗马一贯运作的那样。只是这三个人太强大了，以至于他们真的可以随心所欲地管理罗马。但到了公元前56年，庞培和克拉苏开始决裂。
out. And a guy called Domitius Ahenobarbus who comes from a kind of very distinguished senatorial family he's a massive snob hates detests Caesar and he runs for the consulship on a ticket of cancelling Caesar's command um and so it looks as though everything is going to fall to pieces and Caesar can't have this. So he basically knocks the heads of Pompey and Crassus together. He meets up with them in a place called Lucca, a town which is just within his province. The triumvirate is reanimated. And by the terms of it, Pompey gets the province of Spain for five years. Crassus gets the province of Syria for five years. Caesar gets an extension of his command in Gaul for another five years.
有一个叫多米蒂乌斯·阿赫诺巴布斯（Domitius Ahenobarbus）的人，他出身于一个非常显赫的元老家族，是个极度势利眼，对恺撒恨之入骨。他竞选执政官，其竞选纲领就是取消恺撒的指挥权。所以看起来一切都要崩溃了，而恺撒绝不允许这种情况发生。因此，他基本上把庞培和克拉苏的脑袋敲打在一起。他在一个叫卢卡（Lucca）的地方与他们会面，这个城镇刚好在他的省份之内。三头同盟复活了。根据协议条款，庞培获得了西班牙行省五年，克拉苏获得了叙利亚行省五年，恺撒在高卢的指挥权延长了五年。
So basically, those three men have divided up the most military significant provinces between them. So again, they are effectively impregnable. What then happens over the course of the following years is that that alliance falls to pieces. Well, isn't that partly because it stops being a true umbrage and it becomes a due umbrage? Yeah. And so Crassus, he's basically thinking, isn't he, I'm going to become the big man because I'm going to win a victory that will make me utterly unassailable against the parthians who were the the kind of they're the inheritors of the persian empire aren't they and um i know you'll enjoy telling everybody what happens to crassus well so so crassus basically has he's picked he's absorbed the same lesson that caesar had that you need conquests basically to be at the top table now in Rome.
所以基本上，这三个人瓜分了其中军事上最重要的省份。因此，他们再次变得实际上坚不可摧。在接下来的几年里，接下来发生的事情是，这个同盟分崩离析了。嗯，这难道不是部分因为这不再是一个真正的同盟，而变成了一个双头同盟吗？是的。所以克拉苏，他基本上在想，不是吗？我要成为大人物，因为我要赢得一场胜利，这将使我对帕提亚人彻底无懈可击。帕提亚人是……他们某种程度上是波斯帝国的继承者，对吧？嗯……我知道你会很乐意告诉大家克拉苏发生了什么。好吧……所以……克拉苏基本上吸取了和恺撒一样的教训，那就是你现在在罗马要想处于顶层，基本上就需要征服。
And so he gets Syria because he wants to use it as a base to attack the Parthians. It all goes horribly wrong. It's the first disastrous invasion of Iraq by a Western Republic. And yeah, so Crassus ends up beheaded. And it said either that Milton Gold is poured down his throat or his head is used as a prop in a Parthian staging of a Greek play. It becomes a sort of Christmas tree bauble type thing.
因此他得到了叙利亚，因为他想把它作为进攻帕提亚人的基地。结果这一切都变得一团糟。这是西方共和国对伊拉克的第一次灾难性入侵。是的，所以克拉苏最终被砍了头。据说要么是把熔化的黄金灌进他喉咙里，要么是他的脑袋被当作帕提亚人上演希腊戏剧时的道具。它变成了一种类似圣诞树装饰球的东西。
Yeah. But surely both those things are perfectly possible, Tom, aren't they? Yeah, they are possible, I guess. I mean, pour the gold down first and then cut the head off, I'd say. The story of gold being poured down the throat is one that pops up on a suspiciously large number of occasions in this period. So how accurate it is, I don't know. But that then, of course, means that one of the stools of the three-legged stool has been knocked. And a further disaster for the triumvirate, is now a duomvirate,
是的。但这两件事绝对都是完全可能的，汤姆，不是吗？是的，这是可能的，我猜。我的意思是，先灌金子，然后再砍头，我会这么说。黄金灌喉的故事在这个时期的历史记载中以令人怀疑的高频出现。所以它有多准确，我不知道。但当然，这意味着三足鼎立的其中一只脚被踢掉了。对三头同盟来说——现在已经是双头同盟了——又一个灾难是，庞培娶了恺撒的女儿朱莉娅，并且非常深爱她。但在公元前54年，朱莉娅去世了。所以同样，两人之间的又一条纽带消失了。庞培是恺撒的长辈，对吧？庞培年龄更大。
is that Pompey had married Caesar's daughter, Julia, and had loved her very much. But in 54, Julia dies. So again, another kind of bond between the two men goes. Pompey is Caesar's elder, isn't he? Pompey is older.
不，恺撒年龄更大，我想。噢，好吧。所以庞培娶了恺撒的女儿其实并不算奇怪。不，但庞培自诩为第一人，即元首（princeps）。是的。他是头号人物，每个人基本上都接受这一点。恺撒本质上也接受了庞培的崇高地位。但在公元前54年朱莉娅去世后，以及在公元前53年，恺撒（你知道的）试图把庞培和他的另一个亲戚撮合到一起。
No, Caesar's older, I think. Oh, okay. So it's not really weird that Pompey has married Caesar's daughter. No, but Pompey lays claim to being the first man, the princeps. Yeah. He's the top dog, and everyone basically accepts that. And Caesar essentially has accepted Pompey's primacy. But by 54, when Julia dies, and then 53, when Caesar's, you know, he's trying to match Pompey up with another relative of his.
而庞培拒绝了。到那个时候，情况变得很明显，庞培开始对恺撒的权力和他拥有的庞大军团数量感到有些惊慌。庞培作为西班牙总督，自己也有大量的军团，但他留在了罗马。所以他没有像恺撒那样与他的军团建立紧密的个人纽带。我在开始时说过，对于恺撒来说，公民身份的纽带，我认为是极其重要的。而且我认为他在军营中以及与这些军团（legiones）、每个征集兵的联系中所发现的是，他对这些军团的概念的反应，比他对罗马那些他眼中的萎靡不振的阴谋家的理解，更能真正理解公民身份的纽带应该是什么样的。嗯，这是一个有趣的观点，汤姆，因为有些人——我在前半部分提到了爱德华·哈布斯堡（Edward Habsburg）。
And Pompey says no. It's becoming evident by that point that Pompey is starting to become a bit alarmed by Caesar's power and by the large number of legions that he has. Pompey, as the governor of Spain, has a large number of legions himself, but he stayed in Rome. So he doesn't have the close personal bond that Caesar has with his legions. And I said at the beginning about how for Caesar, the bonds of citizenship are, I think, incredibly important. And I think that what he finds in the army camp and his relationship with each of these legiones, each of these levies, is that he does respond to the idea of these legions a truer understanding of what the bonds of citizenship should be than the kind of what he sees as the effete schemers in Rome. Well, that is an interesting point, Tom, because a few people. So I mentioned Edward Habsburg in the first half.
他询问我们对尤利乌斯·恺撒的看法。他说，他是一个无情、操纵人心的暴徒，导致了共和国的崩溃，还是一个能看清时代征兆的出色军人和立法者？但你暗示还有第三种可能，那就是——我的意思是，那可能包含这两方面的元素——恺撒在自己心里并不是真的在瓦解共和国，
He asked for our takes on Julius Caesar. He says, is he a ruthless, manipulating thug that brought down the Republic or a brilliant soldier and lawgiver that saw the signs of the times? But you're suggesting there's a third option there, which is, I mean, that probably has elements of those two things, that Caesar is not trying, in his own mind, he's not really dismantling the Republic,
而是认为自己更忠实于共和国的精神，因为他认为共和国是由军队而不是由元老院体现的。是这样吗？我不认为他会那样表达。但是，我的意思是，如果你想想克伦威尔在“新模范军”中发现了……是的。对英格兰的一种更真实的代表，比方说比议会更能代表英格兰……是的，这完全讲得通。
but he sees himself as being truer to the spirit of the Republic because he thinks the Republic is incarnated by the army rather than the Senate. Is that right? I don't think he'd do it quite like that. But I mean, if you think if you think of Cromwell discovering in the new model army. Yes. A kind of a truer representation of of England and of England of england than say the parliament yeah that makes
某种程度上有点相似，是的……我们对军团作为独立实体的概念，恺撒确实是那个发展了这一概念的人……所以军团是……你知道的，比如第十三军团，它将作为一个独立的实体一直存在到公元5世纪。它曾短暂地被解散，但在屋大维统治下的内战期间又得以恢复。将军团视为具有对指挥官的独特忠诚的独立实体的这种理念，恺撒才是真正充分利用了这一点的人。而庞培，所有在他在中东时跟随他的士兵都分到了农田，所以他们都离开了。
complete sense kind of slight parallel there and yeah the idea that we have of legions as distinct entities caesar really is the guy who who develops that so the legions is so you know the um the 13th legion for instance that will be a distinct entity right the way up to the 5th century. It kind of briefly gets cashiered, but then it gets revived by the civil wars under Octavian. These idea of legions as distinct entities with distinct loyalties to commanders. Caesar is the guy who really, really leverages that. And Pompey has all the soldiers who followed him in the Middle East have been given their farms, so they've all gone away.
所以在某种程度上，庞培在这方面进度落后了。但转到卢比孔河，汤姆，当恺撒站在卢比孔河边时——我们稍后会更详细地讨论这一点——在某种程度上，他是否认为罗马与他同在，因为他周围的人才是真正的罗马，而远超于此的城市……我认为这占了很大很大的一部分。
So Pompey, in a way, is behind the speed with that. But to throw forward to the Rubicon, Tom, when Caesar is standing there at the edge of the Rubicon, and we will come back to that in greater detail later. Heath, in a way, does he think that Rome is with him because the men around him are the true Rome and that the city beyond... I think there's a huge, huge part of that.
因为他不认为自己背叛了罗马，或者他认为自己忠于这种愿景。这里有一个问题。是的，来自马克斯·帕克（Max Parker）。军队拒绝渡过卢比孔河的可能性有多大？他认为自己忠于这种愿景。这里有一个问题，嗯，来自马克斯·帕克：军队拒绝渡过卢比孔河的可能性有多大？没有，根本没有，因为如果情况是那样的话，恺撒甚至都不会去考虑它。而且恺撒绝对确保了与他在一起的军队、各个军团是支持他的。但我认为，不仅如此，正是军团支持他的这一事实，让恺撒觉得他有权去做他所做的事。这不仅仅关乎他的尊严（dignitas），这并不完全意味着尊严，它更像是他的荣誉、他的价值感、他的成就在应得的回报中体现的那种尊严，而且士兵们也分享了这一点。他们比罗马那些无所事事、阴谋诡计、哭哭啼啼、争吵不休的政客更能理解这一点。是的。那么让我们回到最终分裂前几年的局势。很明显，恺撒和庞培之间的紧张局势正在加剧。据我理解，基本上发生的事情是，恺撒的指挥权即将结束。每个人都知道这将是一次成败在此一举的较量，对吧？因为他基本上……大概他只是吓坏了，如果他放弃指挥权回到罗马，他就会被送上法庭审判什么的。
Because he doesn't think he's betraying Rome or he thinks he's being true to the vision. There's a question here. Yeah, from Max Parker. Was there any chance that the army would refuse the order to cross the Rubicon? thinks he's being true to the vision there's a question here um yeah from max parker was there any chance that the army would refuse the order to cross the rubicon no there wasn't because caesar would not even have contemplated it if that had been the case and caesar absolutely makes sure that the the army with him the legions are with him but i think that that more than that it's the
或者他在政治上受到某种羞辱，从而永远无法再次掌握权力。嗯，关键在于，只要他拥有指挥权，他就享有豁免权，免于被起诉。因此没有人能因其敌人眼中的那些他在执政官任内犯下的罪行而起诉他。没错。但他们都急不可耐。他们都在等待起诉恺撒的机会。因此，对恺撒而言，至关重要的是，当他的总督任期结束时，他要通过获得另一个 magistracy（ magistracy/高级官职）来保持其免于起诉的豁免权。所以他想从总督直接过渡到执政官。因此有一个名叫卡利乌斯（Caelius）的保民官，在公元前52年提议恺撒应该有权在高卢期间参选执政官。
fact that the legions are with him that gives Caesar the feeling that he has the right to do what he does. That it's not just about his dignitas, which doesn't quite mean dignity. It's kind of his honour, his sense of worth, the due that he's owed for his achievements, but that the soldiers share in that. And they understand this better than the kind of do-nothing politicians scheming and whining and scrapping and complaining back in Rome. Yeah. So let's get back to the position in the years running up to the final schism. So clearly the tension is growing between Caesar and Pompey. And there's this basically, as I understand it, what happens is that the end of Caesar's command is approaching. And everybody knows this is going to be make or break, don't they? Because he's basically, presumably he's just terrified that he gives up his command, comes back to Rome, and he'll just get put on trial or something.
而这背后的背景是，恺撒刚刚赢得了他整个职业生涯中最大、最非凡的胜利，可能也是整个罗马军事史上最大的胜利，那就是他在阿莱西亚（Alesia）粉碎了一场高卢起义。任何读过《阿斯特里克斯》的人都会记得韦尔金盖托里克斯（Vercingetorix）走出来，把他的盔甲扔在恺撒脚下。他们就是这么描绘的。而当时的情况是，恺撒正在阿莱西亚这个坚固据点围攻韦尔金盖托里克斯。
Or he'll get politically humiliated in some way that will stop him ever holding power again. Well, the key thing is that as long as he has his command, he is immune from prosecution. So no one can prosecute him for, as his enemies see it, the crimes that he had committed during his consulship. Right. But they're all desperate. They're waiting for their chance to prosecute Caesar. So therefore, for Caesar, it's incredibly important that he maintains his immunity from prosecution by getting another magistracy when he ends his term of governorship. And so he wants to go straight from governorship to a consulship. And so there's a tribune called Caelius, who in 52 BC proposes that Caesar should have the right to run for election to the
韦尔金盖托里克斯的高卢人数量超过了恺撒的军团，但他们被困在了里面。然后高卢人的另一支解围军队赶到了。于是恺撒修建了另一系列防御工事把他们挡在外面。所以他们遭到了两支军队的双面夹击，这两支军队的数量都超过了他们。而恺撒居然赢了。
consulship while he's in Gaul. And the backdrop to this is that Caesar has just won the greatest, most extraordinary victory of his entire career, possibly in the whole of Roman military history, which is where he crushes a Gallic revolt at Alesia. And anyone who's read Asterix will remember Vercingetorix coming out and dropping his armor on Caesar's feet. That's how they portray it. And what happened at this is that Caesar is besieging Vercingetorix in this stronghold of Alesia.
不知怎的，他把他们全部屠杀了。这基本上结束了高卢起义。罗马的每个人都认识到恺撒所取得的成就的惊人规模。甚至元老院也投票决定授予他20天的感恩节。这就是卡利乌斯能够说“好吧，我们认为恺撒的成就足以让他在高卢期间获得这种豁免权并竞选执政官”的背景。现在，恺撒的敌人拒绝容忍这一点。他们太恨他了。这有点像……你知道的，这就是AC·格雷林。
And Vercingetorix's Gauls outnumber Caesar's legions, but they're penned in. And then another relief army of Gauls comes. And so Caesar builds another series of fortifications to keep them out. So they're being attacked on both sides by two armies, both of which outnumber them. And somehow Caesar wins.
AC·格雷林对约翰逊或法拉奇之流的仇恨程度。我的意思是，就是那种程度。所以鲍里斯·约翰逊赢得了这场战役。是的，他赢了。鲍里斯·约翰逊已经……是的，完全如此。基本上，自由派伦敦绝对坚决要无论如何将他们送上法庭审判。所以没有妥协的余地。
Somehow he slaughters them all. And this essentially ends the Gallic revolt. Everyone back in Rome recognises the astonishing scale of what Caesar's achieved. Even the Senate votes him 20 days of Thanksgiving. And this is the backdrop where Caelius is able to say, okay, we think that Caesar's achievements are such that he should be allowed this immunity and to run for the consulship while he's in Gaul. Now, Caesar's enemies refuse to countenance this. They hate him so much. It's kind of, you know, it's AC Grayling.
基本上，双方为此争论不休、争执不下、争斗不止。这其中有一种对那种英国脱欧僵局的微弱回响。因此，推动这一进程的保民官卡利乌斯是西塞罗的朋友，西塞罗是伟大的演说家，他的书信和演讲基本上是我们了解这一时期的主要资料来源。卡利乌斯写信给西塞罗，你知道这种形式：先是就高卢问题达成某种决定，然后有人站起来抱怨，接着另一个人又站起来反驳。于是事情就这样拖延下来，变成了一场漫长而复杂的博弈。这种局面的可怕之处在于，没有人能找到出路，要做到圆满是不可能的。对这个人而言，这绝对是一场噩梦，这个人就是庞培，因为庞培不想被迫做出选择。因为庞培不想被迫做出选择。因为他不想疏远恺撒，特别是当恺撒可能具有如此大的危险性时。
AC Grayling level of hatred for Johnson or for Raj or whatever. I mean, it's that level. So Boris Johnson has won this battle. Yes, he's won. Boris Johnson has, yes, exactly. And basically, Liberal London is absolutely determined they will put them on trial regardless. So there is no compromise.
但同样地，他也不想失去元老院里所有突然开始支持他的新伙伴们的尊重。公元51年，庞培公开反对恺撒，称他应该卸下指挥权……他特别指出，他将像父亲一样对待恺撒——这对他而言极其无礼，是的，你知道的，庞培竟然对恺撒——他自己的岳父——宣称拥有父亲般的权力。汤姆，庞培本可以选择不同的道路吗？庞培本可以想：“好吧，你知道吗？我不想冒引发内战的风险。我基本上已经掌握了一半的权力。”我的意思是，那是他最大的错误，不是吗？
And essentially, it's fought over and fought over and fought over. And there is a kind of slight echoing of that kind of Brexit deadlock. So Caelius, the tribune who pushed that through, is a friend of Cicero, who's the great orator, whose letters and speeches are essentially our major source for this period. And Caelius writes to Cicero, you know, the form, some decision will be reached about Gaul, then someone stands up and complains about it, then someone else stands up in turn. And so it drags on a long, elaborate game. And the horror of the situation is that no one can see a way, it's impossible to square the circle. And the person for whom this is a particular nightmare is Pompey, because Pompey doesn't want to have to choose. Becausey doesn't want to have to choose. Because he doesn't want to have to alienate Caesar, particularly when Caesar is potentially so dangerous.
他本该和恺撒瓜分权力，基本上是背叛元老院。事后看来，是的，那样对他的结果会更好。是的。但我认为，那种……不仅仅是摆出宪法捍卫者的姿态的机会——我的意思是，他是真心相信这一点的，尽管庞培本人在其内心深处曾进行过无数次犯罪般的、违宪的行径——他渴望得到宪政主义者的批准，因此，最终能够摆出宪法捍卫者的姿态的机会，实在是一个太大的诱惑，以至于……一旦庞培倒向宪政主义者，就意味着再无妥协的可能。于是时间来到了公元前50年的12月。两个执政官中的一个前往庞培位于罗马郊外阿尔班山的别墅。
But equally, he doesn't want to lose the respect of all his new chums in the Senate who suddenly are kind of backing him. And in 51, Pompey comes out against Caesar and says that he should lay down his command um and he specifically says that that he is going to act like a father to Caesar so that's incredibly offensive to Caesar yeah you know Pompey is laying claim to the rights of a father over Caesar his own father-in-law Tom could could Pompey have chosen differently? Could Pompey have thought, well, you know what? I don't want to risk civil war. I've basically got half the power. I mean, that was his great mistake, was it?
他拿着一把剑，把剑递给庞培。他说：“我们命令你进军对抗恺撒，以捍卫共和国。”庞培接过剑说：“如果有必要，我会这样做的。”就在那时，很明显（你知道的）将要爆发一场最惊天动地的决裂了，因为现在（你知道的）我们之前讨论过，1月1日执政官交接，保民官交接……公元49年在1月1日上任的保民官，是恺撒在高卢最受表彰、最著名的军官之一，一个名叫马克·安东尼的人。因此马克·安东尼成为了保民官。他是恺撒在元老院的代理人。在公元前49年1月1日，
He just should have carved up power with Caesar and sold out the Senate, basically. As it turned out, yes, that would have worked out better for him. Yeah. But I think that the opportunity to, well, it wasn't just to pose as the defender of the Constitution. I mean, he believed it, even though Pompey himself had engaged in endless kind of criminal, unconstitutional actions at his heart he wanted the approval of the constitutionalists and so the chance ultimately to pose as the defender of the constitution was was too big an opportunity um and so once Pompey has swung behind the constitutionalists it means that the no resolution is. So you go into 50 in December of 50 BC. One of the two consuls goes out to Pompey's villa in the Auburn Hills outside Rome.
安东尼在元老院宣读了恺撒的一项提议，即恺撒和庞培应该同时卸下指挥权。这真是一个相当不错的妥协，不是吗？他为什么不接受呢？元老院认为这可能显得过于有利，因为他们太致力于摧毁恺撒了，以至于他们认为这可能会让他看起来很好，所以他们压制了它。确实如此。同样，你也能看到英国脱欧的回响：通过争取彻底的胜利，他们失去了巩固部分战果的机会。他们非要搞第二次公投，结果却搬起石头砸了自己的脚。
And he takes a sword and he hands Pompey the sword. And he says, we charge you to march against Caesar to defend the Republic. Pompey takes the sword and says i will do i will do it if necessary and that's when it becomes evident that you know there is going to be the most almighty bust up because now you know we've talked about this before first of january consuls turn over the tribunes turn over um tribune in uh 49, who comes in on the 1st of January, is one of Caesar's most decorated, most celebrated officers from Gaul, a man called Mark Antony. And so Mark Antony becomes Tribune. He's Caesar's man in the Senate. And on the 1st of January 49,
他们非要搞第二次公投。完全正确。是的，绝对如此。于是他们投票通过了一个日期，规定恺撒必须在该日期前放弃指挥权。这项决议通过了。当然，保民官的作用，保民官以拥有否决权而闻名。保民官可以否决一项措施。所以安东尼否决了这项措施。
Antony reads out a proposal in the senate from caesar that both caesar and pompey should lay down their commands simultaneously that's a pretty good compromise isn't it why does he take it well the senate decide that this might look too favorable that you know they're so committed to destroying caesar that they they think that that might make him look good so they suppress suppress it. It is. Again, but you can see the kind of the Brexit echo that by pushing for total victory, they lose the chance to bank some winnings. They go for the second referendum and it blows up in their face.
而元老院并没有接受这一点——这就是他们自诩为宪政主义者的理念。当符合他们需求时，他们非常乐意曲解宪法。他们宣布进入紧急状态。所以在1月7日，他们宣布进入紧急状态。安东尼非常非常高调地把自己伪装成一个奴隶，卡利乌斯也是，另一个恺撒派的保民官也是。他们藏在一辆大车里，非常显眼地
They go for the second referendum. Exactly. Yes, exactly. And so then they vote, they agree on a date by which Caesar has to give up his command. And that gets passed. Now, the role of a tribune, of course, the tribunes famously have the veto. A tribune can veto a measure. So Antony vetoes this measure.
朝拉韦纳边境驶去。你怎么能既显眼又藏起来呢？这就是他们的做法，这全都是戏，你知道的。他们确保所有人都知道。哦，所以每个人……换句话说，对，好吧……这基本上是一场表演，具有表演性质，我明白了。对，没错，非常好。于是他们出发前往拉韦纳，恺撒正带着第十三军团在那里等待消息。在史料中，关于保民官确切何时到达恺撒那里，存在一些混乱：有些人说是在卢比孔河之后，有些人说是在之前。但不论如何，消息传到了拉韦纳的恺撒耳中，你知道的，他基本上面临着这个痛苦的抉择。终于，我们最终到达了
And the Senate, rather than accepting that, you know, this is the idea that they're constitutionalists. They're perfectly happy to bend the constitution when it suits their needs. They declare a state of emergency. So 7th of January, they declare a state of emergency. Antony very, very flamboyantly disguises himself as a slave, as does Caelius, as does another Caesarian tribune. They kind of hide in a wagon and very ostentatiously
卢比孔河畔。说到这里，我们休息一下再回来。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你每周必看的
head off to the frontier to ravenna how can you hide ostentatiously that's how they did it it's all theater you know they make sure that everyone knows oh so every so in other words right okay so it's a performance basically it's performative i believe right yes very good so they are and so they head off to ra Ravenna which is where Caesar is with the 13th legion waiting for news and there's some confusion in this in the in the sources about when exactly the tribunes get to Caesar some say it's after the Rubicon some say before but in disputed the news reaches Caesar in Ravenna and you know he basically faces this excruciating decision at At last, we have finally reached
娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐行业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告音频、加更节目和抢先观看现场门票，请前往……卢比孔河，我们收到了很多关于这个时刻的问题。
the banks of the Rubicon. And on that note, we'll be back after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix
所以尼克·R（Nick R）问：“如果恺撒没有渡过卢比孔河，会发生什么？”约翰·O·亨克（John O'Henker）问：“恺撒当时打算做什么？”这里有一种……马克·伍德豪斯（Mark Woodhouse）问：“他从来没有想过不渡过它吗？他还有什么其他选择？”我的意思是，你展现它的方式让我觉得他无论如何都会渡过它，不仅仅是因为……是的，苏拉已经做过这件事了，对吧？他已经进军罗马了。所以对恺撒来说，渡过卢比孔河并不是史无前例的，对吧？所以有各种各样的记载，但是有一个人
of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the Rubicon, and we have had a lot of questions about this moment.
没有对渡过卢比孔河做出记载，这个人就是恺撒本人。所以恺撒写道——就像他曾为自己的高卢战役撰写战地评注一样——他也为内战写了一部战地评注。而且……他的目标（你知道的）是他从拉韦纳出发到一个叫阿米宁姆（Arminium）的小镇。恺撒对此的评论是他带着军团出发前往阿米宁姆。其中完全没有提到卢比孔河。没有提到他跨越了这条河，没有提到他进入了意大利。所以你可能会想，好吧，那所有关于他站在卢比孔河畔（你知道的）沉思和盘算的种种说法，都是从哪里来的呢？
So Nick R says, what would have happened if Caesar hadn't crossed the Rubicon? John O'Henker says, what was Caesar intending to do? There's this sort of... Mark Woodhouse says, was he ever not going to cross it what his other options i mean the way you presented it suggests to me that he's always going to cross it um not least because yeah suller has already has already done this right he's already marched on rome so caesar the crossing of the rubicon is not such a an unprecedented is it so there are various there are various accounts of it but one person who does
我认为几乎可以肯定，这些说法来自于一个名叫盖乌斯·阿西尼乌斯·波利奥（Gaius Asinius Polio）的人，他曾是恺撒麾下的军官，并在卢比孔河畔陪伴着他。他后来成为了一位非常重要的文化人物以及政治人物。所以他是维吉尔的赞助人，是贺拉斯的朋友。他是一个共和国的坚定拥护者，一生都对这一理想保持忠诚。我想他在公元4年左右去世。他说恺撒站在卢比孔河畔，陷入了沉思。然后他说：“让骰子去吧。”
not give an account of the crossing of the rubicon is caesar himself so caesar writes you know as he had written commentaries on on his gallic campaigns he writes one on the civil war as well um and uh his the target you know he goes from ra Ravenna to a town called Arminium. And Caesar's comment on this is he set out with his legions to Arminium. There is no mention of the Rubicon. There's no mention of the fact that he's crossed it, that he's come into Italy. So you may wonder, well, where does all this stuff about him standing on the banks of the Rubicon and, you know, wondering and pondering come from?
他说的是希腊语。好的，不是拉丁语。不。所以这是引用自米南德（Menander）的话：Aneritho cubos. 让骰子抛出吧。让骰子抛出吧，让骰子去吧。现在，在苏托尼乌斯的记载中，这被翻译成拉丁语，即……“Yacta alia est”……是的，那是更著名的版本，不是吗？我的意思是，确实如此。但我看到这里有一个问题，来自
And I think almost certainly it comes from a guy called Gaius Asinius Polio, who was an officer with Caesar and with him on the backs of the Rubicon. He goes on to become a very significant cultural figure as well as political figure. So he's the patron of Virgil. He's a friend of Horace. He's a kind of Republican who stays true to that ideal right the way through his life. He kind of dies, I think, in AD4. He says that Caesar stands on the banks of the Rubicon and kind of ponders. And then he says, let the die be cast.
……艾米·马德里瓦迪（Amy Madrivadi）：我们是否接受伊拉斯谟（Erasmus）的断言，即恺撒说的是“让骰子去吧”而不是“骰子已经掷下了”？有趣的是，……所以我一直在为企鹅经典丛书（Penguin Classics）翻译苏托尼乌斯。我一直在使用的文本，即牛津古典文本，里面写的是
He says this in Greek. Okay, not in Latin. No. So it's a quotation from Menander. Aneritho cubos. Let the die be thrown. let the die be thrown let the die be cast now in uh in suetonius's account it's this is translated into latin as as uh yacta alia est yeah that's the more famous that's the most famous version isn't it i mean it is but there's i see there's a question from
……（原文拉丁语），意思是“让骰子去吧”。所以我们并不知道，是的，他可能没有说过“骰子已经掷下了”或者“让骰子去吧”。我的意思是，最终这并不重要。我想他可能确实说过，我敢打赌，因为波利奥显然记得……你知道的，波利奥是在编造吗？我的意思是，他难道没有这样一句话吗，汤姆……这并不是他说的全部，他难道还说过——在哪里？——“让我们顺从神明的神圣预兆以及敌人的罪恶所引领的方向”之类的话吗？你觉得他说过这话吗？嗯，我们之前讨论过那些有魔力的蛇，对吧？
um amy madrivadi do we accept Erasmus' assertion that Caesar said, let the die be cast and not the die is cast? And interestingly, the, so I've been doing translation of Suetonius for Penguin Classics. And the text I've been using, the Oxford classical text, it has,
在亚历山大的语境下。好吧。所以我会为你朗读我对那段文字的翻译。请讲。它在苏托尼乌斯里。所以根据苏托尼乌斯的记载……消息传到了恺撒耳中，他表现得完全不在乎。他参加了一个公共节日，视察了角斗士学校的计划，举办了一场晚宴……然后太阳落山了，他把附近一家磨坊的骡子套在马车上，
which is let the die be cast. So we don't, know yeah whether he may not have said the die is cast or let the die be cast i mean ultimately it doesn't matter i think he probably did say it i bet because pollio clearly remembered you know pollio is making it up i mean doesn't he have this line tom uh it's not that's not all he says doesn't't he also say, where is it? Let us follow where the omens of the gods and the evils of our foes will lead us or something like that. Do you think he said that? Well, we talked about the magic snakes, didn't we?
带着一小群随从极其机密地出发了，朝着卢比孔河畔驶去。但是……他的火把熄了，他迷路了。于是他胡乱摸索，直到东方太阳再次升起，他才找到一个向导，然后这个向导把他带到了卢比孔河畔。他站在那里，苏托尼乌斯说他当时说：“现在我们还可以退回。但一旦我们跨过了那座小桥，一切都只能由战争来决定了。”然后，根据苏托尼乌斯的说法，一件奇迹般的事情发生了。在他附近，突然出现了一个身材魁梧、相貌堂堂的人物，正坐着吹奏苇笛。
In the context of Alexander. Okay. So I will read you my translation of that passage. Go for it. It's in Suetonius. So according to Suetonius um the news has reached caesar um he affects absolute lack of concern he attends a public festival he inspects the plans for gladiator school he hosts a dinner party um and then the sun sets uh he harnesses mules from a nearby mill to his carriage and he sets
当他的一些士兵——其中还有号手——擅离职守，加入了一大群跑来听音乐的牧羊人时，这个幻影从其中一个号手那里抢过一支喇叭，跳进河里，用一声巨响吹响了进军的号角，然后过河到了对岸。就在那时，恺撒说：“让我们去吧，无论是由神明启发的预兆还是敌人对我们所做的不义之事都在召唤我们。让骰子去吧，或者骰子已经掷下了，随你喜欢。”所以这是一个极其戏剧性的时刻。恺撒渡过了卢比孔河。内战随之爆发。庞培被击败，恺撒所有敌人的军队都被击败了。
off in utmost secrecy with a kind of very small retinue heading off to the banks of the rubicon but um his torches blow out and he gets lost so he blunders about until the sun starts to rise again in the in the east he locates a guide and and this guide then takes him to the banks of the Rubicon. And he stands there and Suetonius says that he says, even now we could turn back. But once we have crossed that tiny bridge, everything will have to be decided by war. And then, according to Suetonius, a wondrous thing happens. Nearby him, a figure of remarkable size and beauty abruptly appeared, sitting and playing on a pipe. And when some of his soldiers, trumpeters among them, abandoned their posts to join the large number of shepherds who had run to listen to the music,
恺撒效仿苏拉让自己成为独裁者。他最终——与苏拉不同的是，他说苏拉放弃独裁权简直是个白痴——恺撒被任命为终身独裁者。正因为如此，他被那些他曾宽恕、曾以自己的宽容（clementia）予以原谅的人暗杀了。是你说的那个 clementia 吗？是的，这最终反噬了他，因为人们感到受到了羞辱，是的，由于他的宽容。而这其中的悖论在于，恺撒宽容他们，是因为在那种（你知道的）中，他是一个真正的共和党人。他不想表现得像苏拉。
the apparition snatched a trumpet from one of the trumpeters, leapt into the river, sounded the advance with a mighty blast and crossed over to the riverbank. And that's when Caesar says, let us go where we are summoned, both by divinely authored signs and by the wrongs our foes have done us. Let the die be cast or the die is cast as you prefer. So it's an incredibly dramatic moment. And Caesar crosses the Rubicon. Civil war ensues. Pompey is defeated, all the armies of Caesar's enemies are defeated.
他不想处决人。他不想为割人头领取赏金。因此，他所宽容的人作为共和国的谋杀者谋杀了她，因为他们能够这样做，而恺撒之所以宽容他们，恰恰是出于无可挑剔的共和主义原因。那么汤姆，你认为那个时刻——最后一个极其微小的细节，如果卢比孔河是一条更像样的河流，那将会是一个更加戏剧性的时刻，不是吗？它是一条糟糕的河流。
Caesar follows Sulla in making himself dictator. He ends up, unlike Sulla, he says Sulla was an idiot for ever having laid down his dictatorship. Caesar is appointed dictator for life and for this, he is assassinated by the people that he has pardoned and forgiven to his own clement is it clementia did you say yeah has come back to bite him because people they feel humiliated yeah by his pardons don't they and the paradox of that is that that caesar pardons them because in that you know in is a true Republican. He doesn't want to behave like Sulla.
因为它基本上比一条小溪大不了多少，不是吗？是的。所以，没有人能真正确定它是哪一条。我想我们至今仍不完全确定，但人们认为它是一条河流——我想直到墨索里尼，墨索里尼好像把它的名字正式改回了卢比孔河。但它原本是菲乌米奇诺河（Fiumicino）。我记得我去寻找过它，结果极其令人失望。它非常非常受污染。它流经工业区，到处都是挂着的罐头和垃圾。所以它被称为 Rubio 是因为它有点生锈的红，
He doesn't want to execute people. He doesn't want to pay bounty money for heads. And so the people he's pardoned murder him as the murderer of the Republic because they're able to, because Caesar had pardoned them for impeccably Republican reasons. So do you think, Tom, that that moment, so just one last, one tiny detail, it would be an even more dramatic moment, wouldn't it, if the Rubicon was a better river than it is? It's a terrible river.
甚至在古代它就含有某种铁沉积物（你知道的），使其变成红色。但正如我所记得的，现在它绝对是一条污浊的河流。不过你认为，在现代语境中“跨越卢比孔河”意味着做出一个改变一切的决定，在此之后便再无回头路。但它真的改变了一切吗？我认为是的。但你不认为接下来的事情在某种程度上是不可避免的吗？共和国体制的衰落、崩溃以及基本上帝国独裁的兴起？还是你认为非得靠恺撒才能让这一切发生？
Because it's basically little more than a, it's just a stream, isn't it really? Yeah. So it's, nobody was really sure which one it is. I guess we're still not entirely certain, but it's thought to be a river that I think until Mussolini, I think Mussolini changed the name officially to back to Rubicon. But it was the Fiumicino. And I remember going to look for it and it's incredibly disappointing. It's very, very polluted. It kind of runs through industrial zones and it's all snagged with cans and waste. So it's called Rubio because it's kind of rusty red,
我认为，如果庞培能吞下他的自负，与恺撒通过谈判达成一项协议，你可以想象会出现一种双头同盟。是的。我的意思是，他们很可能最终还是会爆发内战，但你可以想象（你知道的）他们不会……如果恺撒的反对者不那么顽固的话，你可以想象他成为执政官，然后重新卷入共和派政治的激烈角逐中。所以我并不认为一切都是命中注定的……我认为……我认为（我的意思是）这始终是非常非常可能的。而且我认为，你问为什么我们记住的是恺撒而不是苏拉，部分原因在于……恺撒对罗马的进军对共和国来说是真正致命的。
and even in ancient times it had kind of iron deposits, you know, turning it red. But now it's absolutely filthy, as I remember. But do you think, so to cross the Rubicon in sort of modern idiom means to take a decision that changes everything, after which there is no going back. Does it change everything though? I think it does. But don't you think what follows is to some degree inevitable, the decline of, the collapse of the Republican system and the rise of basically imperial dictatorship? Or do you think it took Caesar to make it happen?
恺撒鄙视（你知道的），是不会做苏拉做过的事的。但我也认为，这是因为你有那种……河流的实物概念。这就是这样一种观念：在河的一边，你拥有共和国；在另一边，你拥有帝国。你知道，在这一边，你拥有自由；而在另一边，你拥有暴政。或者如果你愿意的话，在这一边，你拥有无政府状态和混乱；而在另一边，你拥有秩序。这是未来西方政治中一种原始的分水岭。
I think that had Pompey swallowed his pride and negotiated a compact with Caesar, you could imagine a kind of duumvirate. Yeah. I mean, they may well have still have ended up fighting a civil war but you could imagine you know they they wouldn't um had Caesar's opponents been less obdurate you can imagine him becoming consul and then kind of being embroiled back into the the cut and thrust of republican politics so I don't think it was always inevitable um i think i think i think it's i mean i think it was always very very likely and i think that um the reason that you you asked why do we remember caesar and not sulla partly it's because um caesar's march on rome Rome is properly terminal for the Republic.
这就是它被铭记的原因，因为罗马确实在西方的想象中发挥了这种原始的作用。它一直如此。而共和制政府与专制政府的交相辉映，正是西方政治想象力一直围绕其旋转的伟大极点。我认为这是一个非常令人信服的论点，但这确实提出了最后一个问题，也就是丹尼·凯伊（Danny Kaye）的问题。正如你所说，这在某种程度上是西方政治想象中一个巨大的分水岭，
Caesar despises, you know, is not going to do what Sulla did. But I think it's also because you have that, you know, it's that physical idea of the river. And it's the idea that on one side of the river, you have the Republic and on the other, you have the empire. You know, on one side, you have freedom. And on the other, you have tyranny. Or as if you prefer, on one side, you have anarchy and chaos, and on the other, you have order. And it's a kind of primal dividing line in what will become Western
介于秩序与无政府状态之间，或者介于帝国与自由之间，诸如此类。但为什么偏偏是恺撒被如此彻底地铭记，而真正具象化这种变革的人——最终成为他的养子、他的侄孙、第一位皇帝屋大维·奥古斯都——（我的意思是，恺撒并不是第一位皇帝，奥古斯都才是）为什么偏偏是我们记住了……我的意思是，每个人都听说过尤利乌斯·恺撒。甚至那些对历史完全不感兴趣的人也听说过他。可能甚至很多对历史不感兴趣的人也听说过跨越卢比孔河。但对历史不感兴趣的人通常根本没听说过奥古斯都。我想问，你认为这是为什么？因为奥古斯都掩盖了他的权力。奥古斯都与元老院达成了一项契约：元老院将
politics. And that's why it's remembered, because Rome does serve this primal role in the imagination of the West. It always has done. And the counterpointing of a Republican system of government with an autocratic system of government, those are the kind of the great poles around which the Western political imagination has always revolved. I think that's a really convincing argument, but it does raise one last question, which is Danny Kaye's question. This is such a dividing line in kind of Western political imagination, as you say,
假装比实际更有权力，而奥古斯都将假装比实际权力更小。恺撒没有这样做。恺撒在那种意义上是一个共和党人。他想要他的荣耀，他想要他的尊严（dignitas），他想要他的名望，而且恺撒是一种……他的力量是超凡脱俗且令人敬畏的，他拥有这种大胆、冲劲、毅力，以及渴望成为第一的强烈渴望，这在某种程度上正是共和国一贯的本质，也是共和国之所以成为超级大国的原因。我写的那本关于这的书——《卢比孔河》的副标题是：罗马共和国的凯旋悲剧。这是一本非常棒的书，顺便说一句。
between order and anarchy or between empire and freedom or whatever. But why is it Caesar, who is so totally remembered, when the man who really incarnates that change is the man who ends up as his adopted heir, his great nephew, Octavian Augustus, who is the first. I mean, Caesar is not the first emperor. Augustus is. So why is it that we remember? I mean, everybody's heard of Julius Caesar. Even people who have no interest in history at all have heard of him. And probably even a lot of people who have no interest in history have heard of the crossing of the Rubicon. But people who have no interest in history often have not heard of Augustus at all. I would say, why do you think that is? Because Augustus veils his power. Augustus enters a compact with the Senate that the Senate will
正在收听的听众朋友们应该立刻去买一本。但定义悲剧的一种方式，就是那些在正常情况下会是积极品质的东西，却变成了消极因素。从这个意义上讲，我想恺撒
pretend to be more powerful than it is. And Augustus will pretend to be less powerful than he is. Caesar doesn't do that caesar is in that sense a republican he wants his his glory he wants his dignitas he wants his his fame and caesar is a kind of His powers are demonic and sublime, and he has these qualities of boldness, of dash, of perseverance, of a yearning to be the best, that in a way is the essence of what the Republic had always been and why the Republic had become the superpower that it did. And the subtitle of Rubicon, the book I wrote on this, is The Triumphant Tragedy of the Roman Republic. It's a wonderful book, by the way.
他是一个非常具有共和色彩的人物，但他最终成为了共和国政治躯体中的一种癌症，我猜，所有那些曾为共和国效力的品质，都转而反对了它。乔，我们接下来有一期关于1922年的播客，他就像大卫·劳埃德·乔治（David Lloyd George）。所以斯坦利·鲍德温（Stanley Baldwin）曾说过，劳埃德·乔治，劳埃德·乔治是一股充满活力的力量，但充满活力的力量是一件可怕的事情。
People who are listening should go out and buy it forthwith. But the reason it's one way to define a tragedy is that qualities that under normal circumstances would be positive become negatives and in that sense I suppose Caesar
听众朋友们应该立刻去买一本。但它之所以能被称为悲剧的一种定义，是因为在正常情况下属于正面的品质却变成了负面，从这个意义上讲，我猜凯撒
he's a very republican figure but he becomes a kind of cancer I guess within the body politic of the republic that all those qualities that had been working for the Republic turn against it. Joe, we've got a podcast coming up on 1922, and he's like David Lloyd George. So Stanley Baldwin said, Lloyd George, Lloyd George is a dynamic force, but a dynamic force is a terrible thing.
他是一个非常共和派的人物，但我想他成为了共和国政治体内部的一种毒瘤，所有那些曾经为共和国服务的品质如今都转而反对它。乔，我们接下来有一期关于1922年的播客，他就像大卫·劳埃德·乔治。所以斯坦利·鲍德温说，劳埃德·乔治，劳埃德·乔治是一股充满活力的力量，但充满活力的力量是一件可怕的事情。
And that's pretty much how the Romans think of Caesar, isn't it? They recognize his qualities, but they think they're too much. He has to go. But Augustus is a greater politician, isn't he? Augustus is incomparably a greater politician, but Caesar is a greater man. And if we're talking about greatness in that sense, and we are suspicious of greatness.
这差不多就是罗马人对恺烟的看法，对吧？他们认可他的品质，但认为他太过分了，他必须离开。但奥古斯都是一位更伟大的政治家，对吗？奥古斯都无疑是一位更伟大的政治家，但恺撒是一个更伟大的人。如果我们是在那种意义上谈论伟大，而我们又对伟大抱有戒心。
We've talked about this so many times. But Caesar, indisputably, if there is such a thing as a great man, Caesar was a great man. He was a great conqueror. He was a great political leader. He was brilliant at almost everything he touched. And I think there is something terrifying and, yeah, kind of demonic about it. And if we're talking about 1922, I'm sure WB Yeats, who becomes a senator in that year. Yeats wrote a brilliant poem about Caesar on the banks of the Rubicon. That civilization may not sink, its great battle lost.
我们已经讨论过很多次了。但毫无疑问，如果世界上真有伟大的人这种说法，恺撒就是一个伟大的人。他是一位伟大的征服者，一位伟大的政治领袖。他几乎在他涉足的所有领域都才华横溢。我认为这其中有一种可怕的、甚至有点恶魔般的东西。如果我们谈论的是1922年，我确信WB·叶芝，他在那一年成为了一名参议员。叶芝在卢比孔河畔写了一首关于恺撒的精彩诗篇，为了让文明不致沉沦，其伟大的战役虽败犹荣。
Quiet the dog, tether the pony to a distant post. Our master Caesar is in the tent where the maps are spread his eyes fixed upon nothing a hand upon his head like a long-legged fly upon the stream his mind moves upon silence um augustus does not generate does not inspire that that kind of poetry from virgil maybe or maybe maybe anyway, I could listen to you talking about all this. I could actually listen to you for hours, but I recognise that people listen to this podcast while walking the dog or doing the dishes
安抚那只狗，把小马拴在远处的柱子上。我们的主人恺撒在铺满地图的帐篷里，他的目光凝固在一处，一只手按在头上，就像水面上长腿的苍蝇，他的思绪在寂静中游走。嗯，奥古斯都激发不出维吉尔那样质感的诗歌，也许吧，或者说无论如何，我可以听你谈论所有这些。我其实可以听你讲好几个小时，但我知道人们听这个播客时正在遛狗或洗碗
and that nobody does the dishes for three hours. So we should probably, we will return to the end of the Roman Republic and the birth of the Roman Empire in future podcasts. We have so many plans for podcasts about the Romans. But our path leads us later this week to 1922. And thank you very much, Tom. We will see you all in 1922 next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
而且没有人会洗三个小时的碗。所以我们或许应该……我们将在未来的播客中重返罗马共和国的灭亡和罗马帝国的诞生。我们对罗马人的播客有那么多的计划。但本周晚些时候，我们的道路将引导我们走向1922年。非常感谢你，汤姆。我们下次在1922年再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。想要获取额外单集、抢先收听、无广告收听
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。也就是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。